let's get to audience questions for the
week first one came in from I mean who
says hey David in light of the recent
Trump Republican tax plan which you've
rightly slammed how would you design a
tax plan with the caveat that otherwise
society remains similarly organized
right like we still have for-profit
health care we still have the
educational system that we have we still
have the stock market so it's a specific
question about the tax plan that I would
put together a couple different ideas
that I have number one I think we need
more tax brackets I think that actually
the idea of reducing the number of tax
brackets isn't a good one and I think
that with more tax brackets we could
more precisely define differences
between levels of wealth having the top
tax bracket top out at $400,000 or even
a million dollars there are people who
are really really really wealthy and we
could have higher marginal tax rates for
even higher percentages of people's
income and I think that that would also
allow for doing away with some of the
other loopholes that exist so I think
more tax brackets and higher marginal
tax rates on the highest of those tax
brackets I would also make all medical
expenses deductible okay right now
before the Trump tax plan you could
deduct medical expenses beyond 10% of
your income under the Trump tax plan and
this is one of the few things within the
Trump tax plan that I agree with you
will be able to deduct medical expenses
beyond seven and a half percent of your
income I actually think that that should
either be lowered or there should be no
minimum whatsoever and that is part of
the assuming everything else is the same
if we have a four pot profit tax system
that is mostly employer connected the
way that we have if your employer isn't
providing or subsidizing a tax plan that
is good enough that you end up spending
a lot of money be that ten seven and a
half or five percent of your income on
additional co-pays and expenses then you
should be able to deduct that entire
thing and what that would actually do is
it would rebored in' it would
shift the burden of improving cost when
it comes to health care back to the
government because they actually are
losing out on revenue as a result of
high medical expenses so I would either
reduce or remove that limit that
threshold for deductibility of medical
expense what about elective procedures
though as well seizures I don't know I
maybe not I guess I'd be open to wait
which one did you say oh no you of
course that's not I mean that might be
elective but it's still I think you're
saying more like cosmetics enough right
yeah no knee replacement absolutely
falls under the medical expenses that
should be tax deductible you know
plastic surgery I don't know I guess
I've not thought about it in that much
detail okay so this is like provided
that everything else is the same yeah
that assumes that we don't have a
universal basic income exactly in that
case would you be in support of like a
reverse income tax where if you make say
less than twenty thousand dollars per
year the government is actually paying
you yeah like a subsidy I've talked
about that yeah as far I'm an advocate
of universal basic income and I also
think that a negative income tax in
certain situations is a good idea and
when I talk about more tax brackets some
of those tax brackets could be negative
some of those lower tax and that's
another advantage of having more tax
brackets that you could actually set
some of the lowest tax brackets to
negative rates and it would provide a
sort of universal basic income I think
we absolutely need to be looking at the
taxing of capital gains and passive
income closer to closer to earned income
tax brackets and that is a huge boon and
I benefit from this also as a result of
owning the david pakman show and
receiving income through distributions
from a business that is a huge boon
disproportionately for the owners of
gigantic businesses and the very wealthy
who don't really work for a living so I
think that that's something that we need
to explore as well and then I also think
that we need to maybe restructure
corporate income tax because by and
large the corporate income tax rate is a
ruse that is used as a distraction and
if you restructure that you can sort of
step back from the
bogus argument about oh if you cut the
corporate tax rate it'll stimulate
investment by businesses now it won't
I've already debunked that but if you
were to this is just hypothetical and
now I'm getting more speculative I'm
less sure about this what if you
eliminated corporate tax rates at all
and you made everything pass through and
made it so that the people in the
positions of deciding what's going to be
done with the business profits they are
the ones who would be paying the taxes
on those profits you actually might
completely upend the incentive structure
we have now for businesses to handle
profits the way that they do those are
some ideas I mean yeah certainly an
overview of the topic I didn't mean I
imagine I could understand what your
answers would be when it comes to like
the estate tax yeah oh you're gonna Mum
tax or even sales taxes which are
regressive in some sense the 11 percent
11 million dollar exemption on the
estate tax you got to get that back down
to the five and a half million as a
starting point period and then negotiate
further from from there no doubt about
it